Mr Speaker I know the whole house will
want to thank the emergency services for
their ongoing response to the shocking
incident in Nottingham yesterday
our thoughts are with those injured and
with the families of those who lost
their lives
today is also the sixth anniversary of
the grenfell tower fire we remember the
72 people who lost their lives and
remain as committed as ever to ensuring
that such a tragedy can never happen
again Mr Speaker this morning I had
meetings with ministerial colleagues and
others in addition to my duties in this
house I shall have further such meetings
later today Libra grateful Mr Speaker
can I associate myself with the words of
the Prime Minister our hearts are with
the city of Nottingham and we also
remember those 72 killed at grenfell and
support those still fighting for justice
safe homes
according to the office of national
statistics in January food prices were
rising at 16.8 percent a year the most
recent figures show food prices rising
by a whopping
19.1 making a mockery of his pledge to
halve inflation does he honestly think
people won't notice
five minutes traffic
Mr Speaker of course I acknowledge that
the cost of living is rising for
families and that's why my first
priority of beginner view is the heart
of inflation I'm pleased to say that
inflation is now falling and in the
later set of estimates will remain on
track uh to do so with regard to food
prices we're not alone in experiencing
High food price inflation like many
other countries in Europe that's why the
chancellor has already spoken to the CMA
who are looking at the grocery industry
and we continue to support families with
the cost of living notably by paying
half of their energy bills Paul Z thank
you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker it's a fact
that labor have never left government
with unemployment lower than when they
came in
figures released yesterday show that
there are now four million more people
in work than when labor will last thing
about does the Prime Minister agree that
the security of a good job will always
be better than Labor's dependency
culture
oh Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
absolutely right uh to point out Labor's
poor record on jobs and yesterday's
figures showed that the UK economy is
resilient with the number of people in
employment now at a record level Mr
Speaker why no means complacent but the
inactivity rate continues to fall and
the unemployment rate remains a
historically low levels that is a
conservative government delivering for
our country we don't come to the leader
of the opposition killstama
I joined with the prime minister in his
comments about the terrible attack in
Nottingham yesterday and in tribute to
the work of our Emergency Services the
thoughts of the whole house are with the
victims and the people of that great
City
I also joined him in remembering the 72
people who lost their lives in the
grenfold tower fire
the victims and their families are
always in our hearts but six years on
the Justice they're fighting for is long
overdue
Mr Speaker all across the country people
are worried about their bills the price
of the weekly shop and the spiraling
mortgage rates
so why has the Tory party spent this
last week arguing over which of them
gets a peerage
[Applause]
prime minister well Mr Mr Speaker not my
points on this are very clear in line
with a long established Convention of
previous Prime Ministers having the
ability to submit honors I followed the
process to the letter in conventional
long-standing process it is it is by the
way Mr Speaker a long-standing
convention that prime ministers on both
sides of this house have followed in the
same way that I did here's Starbucks
Mr Speaker
the truth is for all his tough talk
after the event the Prime Minister did
sign off the honors list yeah and that
means that means Mr Speaker that those
who threw a Downing Street party the
night before the late Queen sat alone at
her husband's funeral will now receive
awards from the King
if he's so tough
why didn't you block it
[Applause]
Mr Speaker as I said I and the
government followed due process and
Convention
Prime Ministers Prime Ministers of both
parties have always upheld the
convention of non-interference on
political honors my predecessors may not
have agreed with Labor's choices of Tom
Watson or shami chakravarti
but the same but the same precedent Mr
Speaker the same precedent stood then as
it does now and I'd expect a night like
him to understand that
I think we will have more if we carry on
it'll be more outside rather in here
honor should be for public service not
Tori cronies
[Applause]
the case
Johnson's list
and that also means that those who spent
their time helping cover up Johnson's
law breaking are rewarded by becoming
lawmakers for the rest of their lives is
his message to the British public if you
don't like it tough
that we use the honor System to
recognize people almost 2 000 people a
year from members of the and lionesses
team for the
in Greater Manchester but he talks he
talks about people putting people in the
House of Lords perhaps he could explain
why he put forward for a period the
former MP labor MP Tom Watson who spread
vicious conspiracy theories that were
totally and utterly untrue damaged
public discourse and inflicted misery on
innocent people
[Music]
the said Supply minister
you shouldn't criticize other members
also you're not responsible for the
other parties you are the Prime Minister
that's answering the questions now
asking the question here's some
Okay order order
if somebody wanted to challenge my
decision
Kirsten
Mr Speaker the truth is the country is
paying the price of this endless cycle
of chaos and distraction the Tory
economic crash means that millions of
mortgage holders will pay thousands of
pounds more next year and the blame lies
squarely at the door of a government
more focused on the internal Wars of the
Tory party than the needs of the country
does he not think that those responsible
should hand their heads in shame
Mr Speaker as I said before the
beginning of the session our number one
economic priority is to reduce inflation
so that we can restrain the increase in
interest rates but one thing we know
that we need to do to do that is to
reduce our borrowing and debt Mr Speaker
that's how we will bring interest and
mortgage rates down but last week what
do we see labor confusion with the
shadow Chancellor at
to borrow 28 billion pounds more a year
but she was promptly overruled by the
shadow Energy Secretary the former
leader who said that they were 100 not
abandoning their pledge it really looks
like Labor's offer never changes it's
uncontrolled borrowing and more chaos
with Ed Miller Band
[Music]
there's only one party
there's only one part that broke the
economy and they're sitting right there
and there's a reason there's a reason
they can't fix the problems facing the
country because they never take
responsibility for the damage that
they've done
and it's not just Johnson the prime
minister's immediate predecessor is
hoping to reward those who made her
Reign such a rip roaring success
on her owner's list are the masterminds
of that Kamikaze budget the economic
extremists of The Institute of economic
Affairs those whose disastrous ideas
crashed the economy and left the country
to pick up the pieces will the Prime
Minister block that honors list or will
he Buckle to her as well
Mr Speaker
if you want disastrous and economic
ideas all you have to do is Labor's
economic policy on the energy
[Applause]
policy that seeks to ban all new British
oil and gas drilling Mr Speaker
jeopardizing 200
000 jobs and our energy security at a
time of international conflict despots
like Putin are the only people who will
welcome such a policy okay his pre his
predecessor once said that he wanted
British jobs for British workers his
policy is British jobs for Russian
workers
[Applause]
[Music]
if he spent as much time focused on the
economy the NHS and the Asylum system as
he does handling with his predecessors
about who gets honors the country would
be in a far better state but once again
he's lost control and once again it's
working people paying the price and if
he disagrees with that why not put it to
the test end the boasting the excuses
the Tory chaos see if he can finally
find somebody anybody anywhere to vote
for him and call a general election now
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker he talked about
Asylum just this week just this week it
was the labor party that voted against
Plans to tackle illegal migration just
this week it was a labor party that
voted against Plans to tackle disruptive
protesters by their funding Eco sellers
Mr Speaker but we're getting on and
delivering for the country we're
delivering record employment and the
fastest wage growth in years Mr Speaker
it's clear only the conservatives are
going to deliver for the people of
Britain
jobs
Mr Speaker crime is down significantly
and falling police officer numbers are
at an all-time high but the police
funding formula remains elderly and out
of date and penalizes counties like my
own of Hampshire to the tune of many
millions of pounds previous
administrations have made the commitment
that a new police funding formula would
be in place by the general election can
I invite the prime minister to make the
same commitment Please
Mr Speaker recognize that the current
police funding formula no longer
accurately reflects demands on policing
and that is why the review is carefully
considering local factors for each
police force our priority is to deliver
a robust future-proof funding formula
but it is important that we take the
time to get that right and I know that
the home office will continue to keep
the house updated on our progress we
don't come to live with the SMP Stephen
Flynn
thank you Mr Speaker I would just like
to Echo the sentiments of the Prime
Minister and indeed the leader of the
opposition in relation to the terrible
incident in Nottingham and indeed our
thoughts are with all of those still
reeling from the tragedy in grenfell all
these years later Mr Speaker during his
ill-fated leadership bid late last
summer the Prime Minister warned of The
Perils of mortgage rate Rises indeed he
stated and I quote it's going to tip
millions of people into misery and it's
going to mean we have absolutely no
chance of winning the next election
given that mortgage rates continue to
rise does he still agree with his own
electoral analysis
Mr Speaker which is which is absolutely
why our Economic Policy sets as our
number one priority to reduce inflation
and thereby bring interest rates which
by the way Mr Speaker have also risen in
pretty much every develop economy around
the world more so in places like America
and New Zealand similar in other
countries as well like Australia but it
is important in order to reduce
inflation that you do need to have
control over borrowing Mr Speaker which
is why we unlike the party opposite are
disciplined with regard to the public
finances but these are the issues these
are the issues that we should be focused
on I saw that the SMP yesterday Mr
Speaker had a meeting to discuss their
future but the only thing they managed
to decide was that they should send
Nicola sturgeon some flowers
so can he tell us did he sign the card
I still speak respectfully I think the
the Prime Minister needs to grow up
there is a
there's a and there's an elephant in
this here chamber when it comes to the
dire economic circumstances facing the
UK and that's brexit the Tory benches
they don't want to accept it in the
labor party they don't want to talk
about it but whether it's food prices
Energy prices or indeed mortgage prices
households in Scotland are being shafted
by brexit so can I ask the Prime
Minister will he apologize for the cycle
of misery that Westminster has caused
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
people of Scotland Mr Speaker paying
half of their energy bills making sure
that pensions rise making sure that
there's direct support for those who
need it with the cost of living and
crucially ensuring that we secure over
200 000 jobs by supporting Scotland's
naughty oil and gas industry something
opposed by his party
good afternoon speaker Lincoln will soon
benefit from 20 million pounds worth of
leveling up funding to deliver traffic
bridge over the railway to stop the city
being permanently gridlocked by the
labor City council's huge Western growth
Corridor housing darling this is truly
leveling up for areas of the North in
action will my right humble friend
affirm his commitment to my Lincoln
constituents and businesses that he and
his government will continue to help
level up Lincoln and other areas in the
north of our great country
my uh my honorable friend is fantastic
advocate for his constituents I'm glad
that he and Lincoln City Council were
successful in their 20 million pound
leveling up fund bid the scheme will see
two new bridges built across the railway
line improving access reducing
congestion I very much look forward to
seeing these plans progress and he and I
both share an ambition to make sure that
we level up not just in Lincoln but
across the country
the leader of the opposition recently
ventured out of London visiting my
constituency to deliver a one nation
British labor vision of Scotland however
he neglected to mention that he intends
to continue London's plunder of
Scotland's fast energy wealth just like
the Tories continuing the economic
vandalism of brexit just like the Tories
and denies Scotland's right to
self-determination just like the
tourists so perhaps the Prime Minister
can tell me which London party leader is
the greatest threat to Scottish
democracy the story to my right or the
Tory to my left
prime minister
Mr Speaker I'm I'm not uh I'm not I
apologize I didn't hear fully that the
uh The Honorable gentleman's question
but I did I from what I could gather I
think I think he probably agrees with me
that the leader of the opposition is not
the right person to lead our country
[Music]
prime minister agree that it is
completely wrong for labor to be
introducing new Euless drugs
prime minister yeah well Mr Speaker my
right Uncle friend is absolutely right
to raise this important issue while we
are getting on providing significant
support to families uh with the cost of
living the labor mayor of London to whom
transport has dissolved is busily
putting it up imposing the Euless charge
against the overwhelming views of
residents and businesses it is
disappointing he is not listening to the
British public and the public in outer
London but what's even more his plan to
raise costs on Working Families is
totally backed by the leader of the
opposition
thank you Mr Speaker prime minister new
data from the end child poverty
Coalition and Loughborough University
are shown that your government and
austerity measures have plunged four to
4.2 million children into poverty 70 of
them in working households in Liverpool
Riverside 42 are in working living in
poverty up 7 since 2015. so can the
Prime Minister commit to scrapping the
cruel and any factual to child limit to
lift 250 000 children out of poverty and
meet with anti-poverty organizations
Mr Speaker I'd just like to gently point
out to The Honorable lady that there are
in fact 400 000 fewer children in
absolute poverty than in 2010 and we
also know Mr Speaker that work is the
best route out of poverty for families
so with employment as we saw yesterday
at record levels I'm pleased that there
are now over 600 000 fewer children in
workless households in 2010 on the
specific policy that she raises it
actually ensures fairness Mr Speaker by
asking families on benefits to make the
same financial decisions as families
supporting themselves solely through
work
speaker earlier this
group on coalfield communities published
our report into next steps in leveling
up the former coalfield communities
which I know the Prime Minister has
received a copy of is an inbox as a
proud MP for Newcastle underlying I'm
delighted with the funding that we've
had from governments through the future
High streets fund and the town deal but
there's always more to do so will the
Prime Minister commit to reading our
report carefully considering our
recommendations and working out what
more we can do to level up our coldfield
communities across the whole of the
United Kingdom prime minister
well Mr Speaker I'm very much welcome
the work of the appg for coalfield
communities and indeed the breadth and
ambition of their policy contributions
we are committed to leveling up the UK
by spreading opportunity more equally
across the country investing in and
empowering places that need it the most
and including coalfield communities and
I look forward to discussing and hearing
from The Honorable gentleman further
Wendy Chamberlain you Mr Speaker my
vulnerable constituent whose finances
are held in trust was wrongly billed
four thousand pounds by two energy
companies that now no longer exist as a
result of the energy Market crisis and
energy is one of the most basic services
and there is no Charter rights for
consumers we still don't have this
resolved does the Prime Minister agree
that we need such a charter
Mr Speaker I'll happily ensure that the
appropriate Minister writes The
Honorable lady with a specific response
on her constituents so we can try and
resolve that issue very Sandra you are
Mr Speaker recently the independent
regulator for social housing issued a
state a notice against Birmingham city
council for the state of its social
housing with 23 000 homes not meeting
the decent home standard so over 17
000 homes not receiving asbestos checks
over 15 000 houses not having electrical
safety checks and over a thousand homes
not having fires risk assessments rather
refreshingly an honesty and
astonishingly a League's labor memo put
the blame for this at the heart of the
labor group in Birmingham and so does
the Prime Minister agree with me
um Mr Speaker but it's time that we have
serious intervention in Birmingham to
make sure that people can have decent
homes to live in
Mr Speaker the failings identified in
Birmingham are wholly unacceptable the
regulator for social housing has made
clear that Birmingham must take a media
action to address those issues and will
be monitoring the council's progress
closely I also understand that the
secretary of state has requested a
meeting with Birmingham city council and
will be holding them to account Damien
Hamilton
Mr Speaker
thousands of modular houses every year
in its Factory near Leeds many of which
are completely carbon zero meaning no
bills at all for residents but today it
is facing the prospect of collapse
putting 4 200 future homes and 1 500
current jobs at risk now given that the
home builders Federation says new
housing units could drop to just 120
000 next year does the Prime Minister
now accept that his government scrapping
of housing targets was the wrong
decision
well Mr Speaker it wouldn't be right for
me to comment on the circumstance of any
individual company but what I can say is
I make absolutely no apology for
respecting respecting what local
communities want in their local areas
whilst the party opposite may want to
ride roughshod over the views of local
communities and impose top-down housing
targets and carpet over the green belt
that is not something that this
government will do
thank you Mr Speaker
as we speak the Royal Air Force is
operating the Hercules farewell fly past
over all parts of the UK for over 107
years my constituents of 47 Squadron
have defended our country including over
50 operating the legendary Hercules now
as the Squadron stands down would my
right honorable friend join the whole
house in paying tribute to this
remarkable record of service to this
amazing Squadron they're all men and
women who have made their country proud
well Mr Speaker I joined my honorable
friend in paying tribute to 47 Squadron
their association with the Hercules now
stretches for 45 years and although
their vital work at the heart of Defense
has often been unheralded the Squadron
has served with professionalism and
distinction throughout I think the whole
house will join me in saying that the
Personnel includes can be rightly proud
and they have our full thanks
Mr Speaker my constituents Sarah has
been let down by this government I
elderly father a veteran living of
cancer has developed serious heart
problem his next appointment is
scheduled for November in the cost of
living crisis my constituent paid for
private care as he cannot wait five
months for an appointment he has now
been diagnosed with heart failure
this is the reality of Tory Britain
elderly and sick people that's right
neglected and turned away the
conservatives have broken the NHS and
they're broken Britain yeah the British
public deserves so much better yeah only
in the labor party can deliver this
for the general election
[Applause]
well Mr Speaker I am very sorry to hear
about I believe it was Sarah's father
and I hope he has a speedy and gets all
the treatment that he needs with regard
with regard to the NHS Mr Speaker we're
investing record sums in the NHS but
also with more doctors more nurses more
diagnostic scans to identify cancers
earlier and with elective surgical hubs
to get the wait lists down we're
starting to see progress having
practically eliminated those waiting 18
months but there is more work to do Mr
Speaker and I'm pleased that the NHS is
fully supporting our plan and getting on
with delivering it for people hello
Colburn thank you very much Mr Speaker
can I thank the Prime Minister and the
health secretary for the recent
announcement that the epsomen sent Helia
NHS trust can proceed with plans to
improve and upgrade sent Helia and build
a brand new hospital in Sutton now the
NHS trust is really ready to go they're
further along than other trusts in that
cohort so can the Prime Minister assure
me that when the trust is ready to go
the treasury and the government will be
ready to give the green light to them as
well prime minister well can I thank my
honorable friend for all his uh
campaigning and focus on this issue for
his constituents we remain committed to
the new hospital scheme for the
abstinence and Helia University
Hospitals trust it will deliver a brand
new state-of-the-art facilities as part
of our new hospital program I know the
department are working closely with the
trust to make sure that we can progress
works as soon as possible and expect the
new hospital to be delivered by 2030. Mr
Brenda Sharma speaker
throughout the war in Ukraine the
largest mobile operator Q star has kept
its services operating at 93 percent and
is investing millions in Ukraine's
recovery will the Prime Minister
therefore use next week's Ukraine
recovery conference to bring together
governments and the businesses to invest
in Ukraine's telecoms recovery and
ensure the people of Ukraine are kept
connected with their loved ones through
the throughout the home prime minister
can I thank my honorable friend for the
very thoughtful and Powerful question
he's absolutely right about the aim of
next week's Ukraine recovery conference
Summit which we're very proud to be
hosting and indeed the theme of that
Summit is how to bring in private
Capital to help rebuild Ukraine after
this devastating war and I join him in
paying tribute to all those companies
who in the face of the onslaught that
they are seeing are providing essential
services for the people of Ukraine they
deserve our absolute admiration and
support
speaking last week we acknowledged and
celebrate carers of which there are
thousands across haste beautiful
Hastings and Rye would the Prime
Minister join me in thanking them all
for their Priceless value and
congratulate Hastings voluntary action
in the Isabel Blackman Center receiving
local care for the carers awards for
their support of unpaid carers in our
communities and the outstanding CQC rate
of radfield Home Care in Hastings which
recently won a national award prime
minister I joined my honorable friend in
congratulating carers in her
constituency for all their Awards I'm
also incredibly proud of our Health and
Care staff across the country and
recognize their extraordinary commitment
and I'd also like to pay tribute to
unpaid carers and young carers for all
that they are doing in Hastings and
across our nation Joseph thank you very
much Mr Speaker funding to bring
desperately needed inpatient mental
health better to Bedford is sitting in
the background of our local Mental
Health Trust not to be touched because
of this government's ridiculous Capital
spending limits so will the Prime
Minister will meet with East London
Foundation trust apply some common sense
and find a way to release the cash to
get this mental health unit built so my
constituents don't have to travel miles
to access Services prime minister Mr
Speaker we are investing record sums in
NHS capital and particularly I can tell
the honorable member that we're putting
more money into Mental Health Services
and taking more action than any previous
government at the heart of the NHS
long-term plan is the largest expansion
of Mental Health Services in a
generation I'll ensure that the
appropriate Minister writes to him with
an update on the conversations between
his trust and their local Capital plans
Henry Smith thank you Mr Speaker what
assessment has the Prime Minister made
of the Eurozone being in recession and
the UK economy experiencing growth
Mr Mr Speaker as we've seen recently
it's not just the OVR but the oecd the
bank of England and the IMF who have all
upgraded the growth forecast forecast
for the UK economy you know whilst the
party opposite may want to talk it down
it's the conservatives that are
delivering
yeah yeah
women have
dialed Lee and Northern
Northern I circled domestic violence
incident every 16 minutes and ours is
now one of the most dangerous regions in
Europe to be a woman Stormwind has
consulted on a strategy to tackle
violence against women but there are no
ministers to take it forward the
outstanding women's Aid Foundation
Federation learned last month that their
core funding is being taken away in the
demoralizing absence of a government
will the Prime Minister work with me and
others to ensure that strategy is
enacted and funded so that we can tackle
the cultures and behaviors that are
having such devastating impacts on women
in Northern Ireland
well Mr Speaker I joined with the
honorable lady in saying that it's
absolutely right that we do everything
to Stamp Out violence against women and
girls that's why the government passed
the landmark Domestic Abuse Act set up a
24 7 victim line in quadruple funding
for victim support she's also right to
highlight though that the people of
Northern Ireland are not getting the
local government that they need and
deserve and I want to see that as much
as she does and I'll continue to work
hard to bring that about Philip Davis
one of the Socialist landmines the Prime
Minister has inherited from the former
member for Oxbridge and South ruislip
I'm sure the Prime Minister remembers
him he's the one who said that we should
be more conservative if only he'd had a
majority of 80 and been prime minister
he might have been able to do something
about it
well if
one of the one of the landmines he left
behind was the idiotic Triumph for the
nanny state of banning buy one get one
free and other special offers on
products at the Department of Health
thought was unhealthy now at the best of
times that is an idiotic Triumph for the
nanny state but during the cost of
living crisis it is utterly Bonkers so
can I ask the Prime Minister if he will
intervene pursue a more conservative
agenda as the former member for Oxbridge
would want him to do and scrap this
ridiculous policy yeah well
um can I can I thank my uh honorable
friend he he's long highlighted at this
policy which is why after I took office
given the concerns that he and others
had raised about the impact on the cost
of living we already have a Xeno
postponed the introduction of this
policy no final decisions have been made
but I'll continue to take what he said
very seriously in all our deliberations
Mr Speaker citizens of ice Camry have
told me of soaring numbers of people
coming to them struggling with housing
affordability and last year the monthly
cost of a new mortgage Rose by 61 for
the average semi-detached house and most
fixed rate mortgages coming to an end in
this current 12-month period was set at
interest rates below 2 so the crisis
will worsen for homeowners and renters
yeah so what a price does the Prime
Minister have for my constituents
suffering the consequences of Tory
economic chaos should they cut back on
food switch off the electric and gas or
get further into Tory fueled expensive
debt
well Mr Speaker our number one priority
is to halve inflation so we can reduce
the upward pressure on interest rates uh
his constituents should should know that
what would make that task absolutely
worse is his party's plans for tens of
billions of pounds of unfunded borrowing
which would just exacerbate the
situation but what I would say is for
those homeowners that are worried what
they can do is ask for help through the
support for mortgage interest payment
scheme which has recently been adjusted
that support is there available for them
and memorable from the chancellor has
spoken with the FCA to ensure the banks
treat all those in the difficulty with
the fairness and compassion that they
need that's pure removal Mr Speaker I
was pleased to deliver my report into
the opportunities provided by Deep
geothermal last week and I'm looking
forward to visiting the opening of The
Deep geothermal plant at the Eden
project in the Champion by the member
for Saint Austria Newquay uh next week
will the Prime Minister join me in
meeting with MPS that want to join him
in having the benefits of a deep
geothermal plant and their own
constituencies yeah well can I thank my
honorable friend for his work on this
report I know it's an area that he's
rightly passionate about the government
does support the development of
geothermal projects in the UK providing
it can be done at an acceptable cost to
Consumers and in an environmentally
friendly manner I will ensure that he
gets a meeting with a relevant minister
to discuss his report and ideas further
Lillian Greenwood
Mr Speaker Nottingham is devastated by
the senseless attacks that took place on
our streets yesterday the thoughts and
prayers of the whole city are with the
family and friends of those killed and
with those injured it is absolutely
heartbreaking to see the pictures of
University of Nottingham students
Barnaby and Grace whose young lives so
full of potential have been tragically
cut short
as ever we thank the Emergency Services
who acted quickly and courageously to
save lives
will the Prime Minister ensure that his
government provides the police the
universities and others in our city with
everything that they need to support our
constituents following these horrendous
events
Mr Speaker like the rest of the country
I've been moved by the heartbreaking
tributes from their loved ones this is
an extraordinarily difficult time and
every parent's worst nightmare at the
hearts of the whole country are with the
families and all those who have lost
their lives as The Honorable lady will
I'm sure understand I can't comment
further at this stage given there's an
ongoing situation that the Home
Secretary will be making a statement
after prime minister's questions final
question David Simmons thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker my constituents in
ickenham and South harefield benefit
enormously from the work of the police
based in the nearby Uxbridge police
station which only remains open because
of the campaign by the conservative LED
Council to stop the mayor of London from
closing it down
does my right honorable friend agree
that as we invest in more police those
police need good local police stations
to work from
[Applause]
[Music]
my uh my honorable friend put the point
very well whether it's campaigning to
keep open their local police station or
indeed opposing the Euless charge will
put up costs for hard-working families
it's the conservatives in Oxbridge that
are delivering for their community
that completes prime minister's
questions
well that's there the end of prime
minister's questions and ending uh
really on that second last question uh
from the MP Lillian Greenwood and really
somebody out about the attack in
Nottingham yesterday the Prime Minister
saying that he's been moved by the
heartbreaking tributes from the families
of those who died it is he said every
family's worst nightmare but preceding
that a great deal about the politics of
the day let's discuss what we've just
heard now and I'm joined here in the
studio by our Deputy political editor
Sam Coates uh Sam what did you make of
the exchanges between kirst armor and
the Prime Minister as expected much made
of of The Rao about peerages cost of
living once again raising its head
that's right I I kind of felt we were
stuck in this pattern that we've been in
first for some time kirst armor
basically started by asking why given
more mortgage rates are so high
Sam we're going to cross back because
the Home Secretary is making a statement
Russia police have confirmed
that a 31 year old man has been arrested
on suspicion of murder after three
people were killed in Nottingham City
Center early on Tuesday morning
the same individual is suspected of
stealing a van and then running over
another three people who are now being
treated for their injuries one of whom
remains in critical condition
we know that a knife has been used in
these attacks
and two of the victims were students at
Nottingham University
the third victim was the owner of the
van that police suspect was stolen and
used to run down those pedestrians
I know that the whole house will join me
in expressing our sorrow and that our
thoughts and prayers are with the
victims families friends and all those
affected
all of us extend the hand of friendship
to the people of Nottingham
I'm of course being fully kept and being
kept fully informed by law enforcement
on the ground and receiving regular
updates
Mr Speaker the house will appreciate the
critical importance of following due
process at all times
it's completely natural to seek answers
immediately when something terrible
happens
but it's also vital that those answers
are wholly accurate
speculating out loud is never helpful
and runs the risk of being
counterproductive
the police have asked for patience while
the inquiries continue Mr Speaker
I can tell the house that the police are
working flat out to establish the full
facts and provide support to everyone
affected
they are currently keeping an open mind
as to the motives Behind these attacks
but I can confirm Nottinghamshire police
are being assisted in their inquiries by
counter-terror police though this does
not mean that it is currently being
treated as a terrorist attack
I'm grateful to all our emergency
services for being on the scene and
dealing in a professional manner with a
deeply distressing situation
we all owe them a huge debt of gratitude
at awful moments like this Mr Speaker it
is vital that we come together as a
country
and I have no doubt that we will
the city of Nottingham and all its
people are at the Forefront of all our
minds
and every resource of the state is at
their disposal and I commend the
statement to the house we don't come to
the shadow Home Secretary of that group
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank the
Home Secretary for her statement for
advanced sight of it and join with her
and with the whole house in expressing
our deep sorrow and shock at this truly
awful attack
the families of those who have been
killed have expressed their tributes to
their lost loved ones and so I joined
them in paying tribute to Barnaby Weber
and Grace Kumar to Young talented
students who had hugely promising
Futures ahead of them we've seen the
tributes from their heartbroken families
and also from the local and national
sports clubs that they played for we pay
tribute to to Ian Coates a school
caretaker we've also seen the tributes
from his family and the school he worked
for who said he always went the extra
mile for them
and our condolences thoughts and prayers
go to their families their loved ones
their friends and colleagues and our
thoughts and best wishes to go to the
three other people who have been injured
in this same terrible attack and to
their families who will be so deeply
distressed at what has happened worrying
for their loved ones
and we stand in solidarity with the
people of Nottingham and the University
of Nottingham where the two young people
were studying all so shocked and
devastated at what has happened
but also so determined to come together
in the face of tragedy people who
gathered vigil last night the sober
words and tributes from the council
leader from local MPS local faith and
Community leaders
and everyone particularly will join in
thanks to the emergency services who
have had to respond to this awful attack
saving lives and keeping people safe
as the Home Secretary has said an
individual has been arrested and this is
still a major ongoing investigation and
it is not appropriate for us to
speculate or say anything that would
interfere in that investigation
but can I welcome the involvement of
counter-terror police at an early stage
of this investigation that does nothing
to preempt any conclusion about the
potential motive behind this attack but
I have raised in the past the importance
of having CT police expertise involved
at an early stage while motives and
circumstances are investigated rather
than being brought in at a much later
stage once relevant material has been
gathered so can the Home Secretary
confirm this is a sensible approach for
the expertise and assistance of the
counter-terror police to be drawn on at
an early stage even before any
conclusion has been reached and can she
tell us if she's been given any
timetable for updates on this issue so I
know there are also wider concerns about
the need for properly coordinated and
appropriate sensitive support for the
victims of major incidents including
Terror attacks so can she set out what
support is available for the families
and friends of those is affected and for
the services and people in Nottingham
doubtless there will be countless more
questions for the community and for
Parliament once more is known about this
Dreadful attack but for now we send our
support to Nottinghamshire police in
their investigation and all our thoughts
and solidarity to those who have lost
loved ones and to the people of
Nottingham at this difficult time
homes
I thank the right honorable lady for her
comments um and the sentiment in which
she makes them
um the Nottinghamshire police are
leading the investigation it is uh they
are at a very early stage and they have
carried out a number of searches uh a
number of inquiries across the city and
they will continue to gather evidence
across over the coming days and police
and other agencies are working flat out
to establish the full facts and provide
support to everyone affected as I said
and I'll reiterate the police have asked
for time and space and patience while
those inquiries continue I'm being kept
regularly updated
by the police and agencies on the ground
there is uh the families of all of the
victims have been informed and are being
supported by specialist police offices
as there are casualties and three
fatalities uh there are there is a real
need for uh emergency care for those
families as you would imagine and
specialist support is being put on for
those who are directly affected but I
Echo the sentiment of the house uh as
expressed by the Prime Minister that we
are all saddened shocked and our hearts
are with those affected the victims
their families their friends their
communities and the City of Nottingham
thank you Mr Speaker when a Despicable
incident of this sort occurs whether it
be at the gates of parliament or on the
streets of a University Town
the community looks to the security
agencies to be able to investigate and
establish the motives for the attack the
background of the attack and whether any
other people were involved does the Home
Secretary agree with me that it is
therefore both important and
understandable why the intelligence
Community has the capacity that it has
to investigate people's online life for
example and why the high-tech companies
that provide these communication
Services have a duty both morally and
legally to cooperate with the security
community so that horrible episodes like
this can be fully investigated and the
findings established Bob secretary
my radar often makes some very pertinent
observations
the Emergency Services work together
to respond to suspected terrorist
attacks through the joint Emergency
Services interoperability principles
Jessup and they're designed to improve
joint working between all of the
emergency services and that the the
Jessup joint Doctrine complements a
single service and specialist
multi-agency guidance and when there is
a particular attack with an online
element which he refers we will enact
our crisis response protocol which is an
element of practice which has been
designed to deal with situations where
of that of that character
supposed personal
thank you Mr Speaker and I think the
secretary for advanced sites of her
statement on behalf of the Scottish
national party outstanding their
condolences to the families and the
friends and loved ones of Barnaby Barber
Grace Kumar and Ian Court sent our
thoughts are with those also injured and
with the people of noticing more widely
and I would like to express our thanks
also to all the emergency services and
those providing ongoing support to those
affected at this time can I ask the Home
Secretary what more has been done to
provide reassurance to all parts of the
community in Nottingham and to prevent
the the spelling of speculation that
she's mentioned in her statement and
although I appreciate that things are in
a very early stage indeed what process
will she put in place to ensure that all
the lessons are learned from this
shocking incident so that this cannot
happen again
home search well the Nottinghamshire
police working with local authorities
and agencies are working intensively to
ensure that not only the investigation
work is carried out effectively but also
those who are directly affected by this
terrible incident are getting all the
support they are entitled to
Patrick
Mr Speaker yesterday's horrific attacks
in Nottingham City has devastated our
counting three innocent lives have been
lost and I'd like to offer my deepest
condolences to the families of those who
have died and my thoughts to those who
are injured
I'd like to thank the emergency services
for the work they have done
the town of Beeston in my constituency
of broxtow as a large student population
they and many members of the public will
currently be feeling shaken and Afraid
I would ask the Secretary of State for
reassurances that all will be done to
support the families our student
population and our communities at this
very difficult time
Home Secretary
well it's
particularly galling that there is a
vibrant
youthful university community which will
be so tragically affected by this tragic
incident and the university is
supporting the students family and
friends as well as staff and the student
body they're working very closely with
the authorities on the ongoing
investigation into the accident into the
incident and there's extra state for
education has been in touch with the
vice Chancellor of the university to
offer any support that might be needed
from the Department for education
show the select committed Dave Daniel
Jones Mr Speaker and can I thank the
Home Secretary for making this statement
today and for the information that she
has been able to pass on to the house
and I look forward to further updates in
the coming weeks can I also extend my
thoughts and prayers with all those who
are killed and injured their families
and friends and of course we all
recognize the Viper role of the
emergency services in dealing with these
very fast-moving incidents and I just
wondered if the whole secretary might be
able to say if she's identified any
additional support that Nottinghamshire
police need at this time
Home Secretary well I am in personal and
regular contact with the chief Constable
of Nottinghamshire police and I have
made that offer very clear to her we are
we stand ready here at the home office
to help in whatever way she requests but
to date this operation is being led very
effectively by the chief constable in
Nottinghamshire and with with her team
thank you Mr Speaker as a proud
Nottingham I have to say it's been a
very difficult couple of days for us all
and um particularly uh for those who
represent uh people in the areas
affected uh but would the Home Secretary
join me in praising the emergency
services for the work they have done for
reacting so quickly and not just the
whole community of Nottingham but
particularly our students our
universities and joining with us as a
house to do everything that we can to
support them going forwards
my honorable friend uh speaks for his
constituents and the people of
Nottinghamshire when he sets out uh our
thanks admiration and gratitude for
those uh on the front line and in the
emergency services who are responding
right now to the tragic consequences of
this terrible incident they are heroes
and we must thank them day after day for
their fantastic work
thank you Mr Speaker I'd like to send my
deepest condolences to the families and
friends of the victims of yesterday's
attacks and to wish a full recovery to
those injured I would also like to thank
the Emergency Services who've been
working tirelessly responding to this
tragic incident including the First
Responders who battled to save lives at
the scene
Nottingham is devastated by the deaths
of three residents of our city Grace
Kumar Barnaby Weber and Ian Coates it
was incredibly moving to join the vigil
yesterday at St Peter's Church where
hundreds of people came together in
grief among the many students who lost
too much loved members of their
community
will the Home Secretary join me in
paying tribute to the people of
Nottingham to their unity and resilience
at this painful time
of secretary The Honorable lady speaks
with passion and care for her
constituents and I I Echo the sentiment
that she's expressed the people of
Nottingham will be shaken beyond belief
over the events over the last few days
we are with them as a nation and we
stand by them with them and we will
support them in all ways that they need
Tom Randall
speaker Nottingham is a great city with
a proud history and a bright future so
to see that these crimes have unfolded
across my home city has been deeply
upsetting and will the Home Secretary
I'm sure a whole house will join me in
sending our deepest condolences to the
victims their family and friends and to
the injured and to thank the police in
the emergency services for the work that
they have done and will continue to do
and as we begin to take stock from what
has happened and to cope with what has
happened I know that there is support
available for those who have been
effective for example from the
Nottinghamshire victims care service so
will the home sector should join me in
encouraging those who have been affected
by this in any way just the super
support that they need as we begin to
take stop Tech stock and begin that low
slow process of recovery over this this
Dreadful incident obsession
well there has been a magnificent
response from the local authorities in
the local emergency services and in
particular with regard to the families
and those who are affected uh because of
the incident there is a wide range of
extensive support which is currently on
offer for them and those who are
effective shouldn't hesitate to get in
touch with the local authorities to seek
that support
living real thank you Mr Speaker
everyone in Nottingham was shocked by
yesterday's senseless
tax
Barnaby and Grace were just walking home
after a night out Ian appears to have
been on his way to work
today many people in our community are
feeling incredibly frightened fearful
even to walk down their own Street
will she give a commitment to our city
that she will ensure Nottinghamshire
police has the resources it needs not
only to keep our city safe but to
provide all our residents with the
reassurance that they need to live their
lives without fear today in the weeks
and in the months ahead yeah
[Music]
well I Thank The Honorable lady for her
uh her words that she's absolutely right
the people of Nottingham will feel grief
they will feel fear and they will feel
profoundly disturbed by what has
happened their homes their places of
work uh where they come from it is going
to affect people in many many ways we
want to keep them safe that is my job
that is the police's job that is why the
police are working intensively right now
not only to secure uh the uh environment
and to make sure that an investigation
is conducted effectively we need to
support them in their work